[Music]
this is dave klein reading for heidi
kemps
there's no denying the appeal of classic
sonic the 16-bit sonic games are some of
the most memorable and influential
platformers around no matter what
happens with modern day sonic the old
games remain as wondrous and as exciting
as ever a sort of gaming comfort food
you can keep coming back to for years on
end it's no surprise then that sega has
re-released the classic sonic games many
many times over in various compiled and
standalone forms sonic origins is the
latest such compilation with its main
selling point being that the games have
been completely rebuilt by many of the
staff behind the beloved sonic mania and
while the games remain as delightful as
ever the package as a whole feels a
little disappointing sonic origins
contains four technically five since
sonic 3 and sonic and knuckles were sold
separately classic sonic games from the
16-bit era the original sonic the
hedgehog sonic cd sonic 2 and the
combined sonic 3 and knuckles rather
than the emulation most re-releases
utilize each of the games have been
rebuilt in a new engine to play almost
exactly like their original versions
though with various quality of life
improvements added sonic 1 for example
has a spin dash and fixes the infamous
instant kill spike bug while sonic 2
adds a new level the mythical hidden
palace zone and sonic 3 and knuckles has
touched up sprite animation for its
cinematics and the supersonic
transformation and so on in addition
characters who might not have been
playable in the original releases also
are made available such as tales and
sonic cd and knuckles in sonic 1.
knuckles still isn't in sonic's tv
likely because his playstyle really
doesn't match the way that game's levels
flow
most of the original visuals and music
remain intact though some of sonic 3's
music long theorized of the involvement
of michael jackson by the way has been
changed likely for legal reasons all of
the games have a new anniversary mode
that increases the viewing area to 16x9
as opposed to the original 4x3 aspect
ratio and removes the live's counter you
can still die of course but you'll just
respawn at the last checkpoint making
the threat of a looming game overmoved
coins can be collected within the games
from power-up monitors getting lots of
rings and clearing special stages you
can then spend these coins to unlock
extras in sonic origins museum or retry
when you fail to get the chaos emerald
in a special stage it's a great feature
for sonic 1 and sonic cd where
opportunities to enter and clear a
special stage are quite limited less so
for sonic 2 and sonic 3 knuckles where
opportunities are more plentiful and you
can then blaze through the rest of the
game as supersonic if you prefer the
old-fashioned handling of lives and
special stages however you can choose to
play the games in classic mode instead
complete with the original 4x3 aspect
ratio while still keeping all of the
various additions and touch-ups
every game now has brand new and
exceptionally well done animation
sequences in its opening and endings as
well as an unlockable mirror mode which
flips the levels to run right to left a
boss rush and a story mode that allows
you to play all of the games in sequence
as one big sonic adventure finally
mission mode sees you attempting various
challenging tasks in modified classic
stages to earn coins there are some very
fun and creative missions but sonic
veterans will likely blow through them
all really quickly and the only way to
get more of the hard missions is to fork
over cash for some day one dlc
not that you really need more missions
to earn coins as completing all the base
missions will give you a treasure trove
of coins with which you can unlock
practically all of the museum content
easily leaving you to sit on the rest of
your earnings with practically nothing
to use them on the museum content is
rather disappointing in general there's
a lot of concept art that's already been
seen in other sonic titles and
collections classic music remixes that
have appeared in other games like super
smash brothers sonic generations and
even the recent sonic forces and
animatics of the new intro and outro
sequences it feels like there could have
been a lot more where are all the
commercials and weird sonic media we
haven't seen since sonic jam way back on
the saturn for example it's not just the
extras that feel a bit lacking either
sonic origins has some puzzling issues
and omissions that you wouldn't expect
in a retro compilation of this caliber
there's no save state slash reload
functionality nor are there any screen
filters that can help smooth the pixels
into a nice crt-like look there is one
anti-aliasing screen option that makes
the screen look like it's been smeared
with petroleum jelly
but that's it the sound balance seems
wonky at times too with the bass sound
level a bit muffled while certain sound
effects and sequences are way too loud
in comparison it's also disappointing
that playing with the traditional life
system limits you to 4x3 aspect ratio
similarly oversights like wallpaper
options for 4x3 being locked behind paid
dlc and needing to replace standalone
sonic cd in order to unlock all of the
stages for time attack even when the
game has been completed in story mode
are a dampener on the experience
don't get me wrong the games remain
excellent and the painstaking dedication
to recreating the complex levels and
gimmick interactions of the various
sonic titles is wonderful to behold it
warms this aged sonic fan's heart to see
the faux rotation of special stages and
assorted stage objects made much more
smooth to see super sonic get new design
accurate animation frames instead of
reusing a bunch of those belonging to
regular sonic and to finally have a
dedicated super button in sonic 3 and
knuckles so i can transform only when i
really want to
and the long lost hidden palazzone
brought to life by the talented hands
that created the fantastic levels of
sonic mania is like my childhood
imagination made manifest it's a
gorgeous stage filled with sleek curves
and glowing gemstones providing a
delightful mix of unique enemies and
gimmicks that give it a personality of
its own along with a very clever boss
design at the end but even the
recreations of the games themselves have
some issues with strange bugs that
weren't present in the originals partner
tails in sonic 2 has a bad habit of
getting stuck in places and trying
desperately to reach you for a very long
time before his flyback to sonic routine
kicks in leading the stages filled with
the obnoxious background noise of
constant jumping and spin dashing
[Music]
some of the transitions in sonic 3
knuckles don't quite work right i got
stuck at the transition to sandopolis 2
and could only proceed after pressing
the option button
and sometimes the death slash respawn
checkpoint system in sonic 3 knuckles
feels really off i've had multiple
instances where i die and not respond at
the stage start rather than a checkpoint
i'd touch or respond with a shield
intact after pit or crushing death and
even seen a good chunk of his stage's
checkpoints marked as touch before i
even encountered them in terms of dlc
for an additional cost you can get a
bunch of hard missions some extra
wallpapers for use in classic mode
additional music and decorative extras
and camera angles on the menu screens
given the relative death of unlockable
extras charging money for these features
leaves a sour taste in my mouth with so
many coins i'm not using these feel
perfect for including as unlocks i can
earn through normal gameplay
instead it's available at an extra fee
to bolster an already unsatisfying
offering i know a lot of my problems
with sonic origins sound like nitpicks
but i adore these games and i want to
see them restored and presented with joy
and reverence as the masterpieces they
are
not tainted with frivolous dlc that
should be unlockables and lackluster
presentation sonic origins comes close
to being the definitive classic sonic
experience but stumbles just before the
finish line
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you